peut rester comme ça bon je pense qu'on
peut commencer tranquillement à bob
bonjour à tous moi c'est les donc
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler
d'apprendre à se comprendre mais avant
nous parler de tout donc en fait deux
choses en face et que en fait c'est un
peu une répétition là pour du matériel
pour la venue de monsieur fille qui
viendra donc la semaine prochaine
dans deux semaines le 16 mai à 17 heures
à venir nombreux il va nous parler de
super intelligent sait comment penser
intelligemment à super intelligence et
pour ceux qui ne connaissent sur
internet comme ça veut dire sans doute
thibault monsieur prix c'est vraiment un
mec génial passionnant par super bien
c'est un petit peu la pensée à venir
dans deux semaines et puis la deuxième
chose c'est que c'est un petit peu
expérimentale à la fois dans les youtube
live on est dire en direct sur youtube
pour ceux qui n'ont pas compris et c'est
aussi l'expérience à long terme de ce
sujet parce que le sujet dont je vais
vous parler aujourd'hui apprendre à
apprendre je pense que c'est une
question à la fois vraiment on est
confronté très souvent surtout dans le
cadre d'une université comme ici 5 et 10
centres apprendre et comprendre je pense
que aussi les chercheurs sont de plus en
plus confrontés à cette question
notamment les intelligences
artificielles et donc est ce qu'on peut
comprendre une ia qu'est ce que fait le
diplôme c'est un algorithme et youtube
ces grandes questions c'est un peu c'est
des grandes questions et envie de
comprendre ce qui se passe mais en fait
c'est même pas clair de savoir ce que ça
signifie que de comprendre une
intelligence artificielle est donc
aujourd'hui on va essayer un peu aussi
je sais vous suggérer des idées sur
qu'est ce que pourrait bien signifier
comprendre et se voir la différence en
tout cas avec à prendre
donc mais du coup je vais présenter
aucun programme donc un truc très solide
aucun truc publié ce sont un peu des
idées comme ça en fait elles sont pas
vraiment pas publier encore mais encore
fait ça fait partie aussi de d'un livre
écrit envoyé à la version finale
aujourd'hui et qui sera publié dans
quelques mois qu'ils parlent un peu
aussi par la forme de baisses plus
généralement mais qui essaie de se poser
la question de kss kss kss que le savoir
finalement donc voilà pour cette intro
donc apprendre versus comprendre donc
comme on l'a vu c'est je pense quelque
chose de très important sein d'une
université à son cursus scolaire
vous souhaitez une différence entre à
apprendre et comprendre si vous retours
sont qu'est-ce qui se passe donc on sent
que les différences entre apprendre et
comprendre et on sent que d'un point de
vue pédagogique et on est qu'il ya des
examens qu'on est capable de réussir
sans avoir appris sans avoir compris à
prendre et c'est un petit peu gênant du
coup on quand on est enseignant en tout
cas on a envie parfois de dirar est
d'apprendre et commence à comprendre mes
choix
qu'est ce que ça veut dire du coup quand
on est quelqu'un de comprendre
et puis l'autre cas important c'est le
machine learning
il ya des titres assez récurrent de
pardon cela qui dit que machines le
machine learning fonctionne mais
personne n'est au caire mathématicien
mais c'est pourquoi aussi longtemps que
les mathématiques ne comprennent pas ce
qui se passe derrière la machine
learning et c'est pas forcément très
clair de savoir qu'est ce que
signifierait que de comprendre la
machine sommes donc avant d'aller plus
loin on qui à la différence entre
apprendre et comprendre et notamment
régime il est synonyme se quittant l'île
me semble à peu près synonyme à prendre
je pense que ce soit on associe souvent
savoir reconnaître alors que comprendre
ça serait plus maîtrisée d'une certaine
venir mais bon avant d'aller plus loin
testez vos micros j'aimerais vous
inviter à ac2
donner vos avis quelqu'un qui n'aura une
réflexion sur quelle est la différence
entre apprendre et comprendre quelqu'un
veut prendre la parole c'est un gars pas
vos visages je dirais que ça marche
ouais est-ce que ça je dirais que le
comprendre c'est être capable de
généraliser des nouvelles données
inconnues
si on connaît toutes les questions on
peut apprendre toutes les réponses mais
si on ne nous est pas donné les
questions on est nécessairement obligé
de être capable de généraliser cette
question s'est enfin quand tu dis à
prendre ou savoir et comprendre vous
maîtrisez moi j'aimerais apprendre et
comprendre c'est puis ce moment de fin
août acquiert quelque chose de nouveau
alors que le mans où tu maîtrises et où
tu sais c'est la postériorité du coup je
vais pas trop savoir comment tu veux
poser le débat parce que c'est le moment
de l'acquisition de nouvelles
connaissances
[Musique]
je suis assez d'accord avec le
généraliser ils peuvent faire ça très
très bien parce que c'est à dire qu'ils
comprennent ce qu'ils font une question
d'âge
j'ai l'impression qu'il ait pas de
france marque pour youtube n'est pas
moins cher au système
peut-être que apprendre c'est pas
reproduire et comprendre c'est ça
d'avoir à expliquer je vais prendre un
exemple je dois expliquer à un apprenti
les fonctions affine qu'il est censé
avoir acquis mais qu'il ne comprend pas
il est capable d'appliquer les méthodes
mais si on le dit d x égal avec ce plus
bas il va comprendre si on y avait deux
tega la hâte et plus ce cas il comprend
il n'arrive pas transposé parce qu'il a
appris avec knicks mais il comprend pas
la fonction à finances en soi du coup
j'ai un ami qui disait de ses élèves
qu'ils avaient quelques qu'une somme de
1 jusqu'à nice avait fermé donc jusque
là qu'elle s'était perdue changer le nom
d'eva blanc et ça fait partie on sent
que quelqu'un qui trop enfermé sur
certaines notations qui comprend pas
juste ça parce que là tels que je
comprends ça serait juste apprendre un
truc et apprendre de fréquences
variables le changement de nom de
variables combiné de hm est justement là
moi je sais pas qu'est-ce qui lui
échappe
dans les fonctions hafid et donc
j'arrive pas à lui expliquer et trouver
une méthode pour qu'ils puissent
comprendre et pas juste à pic
peut-être une différence entre apprendre
et comprendre c'est que comprendre on
sait pour enfin on sait pourquoi on fait
on arrive à dire ouais ok on a fait une
arrivée généralisée et à savoir en
termes de vrai pourquoi le faire et
apprendre n'était pas forcément le cas
j'ai une réponse un peu plus sérieuse un
peu historique si je ne pourrais pas un
exemple en fait quand on a dérivé la
première contre 1 trouver l'algorithme
qui résout les équations de second degré
c'est un bon exemple
la personne qui a trouvé cet algorithme
a permis à des gens après de résoudre
des équations de second degré sont les
comprendre qu'en j'applique delta égal à
becca raymond cote assez je trouve la
première solution la deuxième solution
j'appuie je suis en train d'appliquer un
algorithme que j'ai appris que quelqu'un
a donné
est ce que à prendre c'est pas par
exemple le travail de celui qui a tout
fait l'algorithme de delta mais
carrément catégorie tenir un rôle il mit
en l'occurrence celui qui va faire le
travail d'apprentissage comprendre c'est
un ferrer la règle est delta etc et vous
trouverez les solutions et dans
comprenant permet à des gens qui ne
comprennent pas forcément un problème de
le résoudre
on leur donne un algorithme et todd
naturel de pythagore
pour rappel
voir ici et du coup tant de morts juste
la version simple qui nous dit que si on
a un triangle rectangle
alors le carré de l'hypoténuse est égale
à la somme des carrés des deux côtés
opposés
il ne le connaissez tous vous savez ce
que c'est parce que vous le comprenez et
à ça c'est vraiment un exemple de ça
fait 20 ans que je connais et voilà
pourquoi pas cet exposé je ne suis si
l'intéressé à nouveau chercher la preuve
et je n'ai pas trouvé soit facile à
prouver
j'ai bien galéré en tout cas en tout cas
la preuve original la preuve original
d'euclide donc on va y aller par étapes
en fait la première étape c'est
peut-être de dire ça en fait on va
séparer le carré en deux parties qui
correspondent vers un kilo à ce mélange
ensuite on va essayer prouver que les oh
oui je parle trop fort ok ok énorme et
je vais parler pas monter le son les
héritiers de régler ça quand je là là on
va peut plus utiliser l'autre au micro
donc priori ça devrait être bon donc
donc je dirais que le terme de pythagore
en fait si on regarde la preuve général
de qu'il en fait c'est vraiment ça qui
dit quand j'étais gamin je vais rater
galvaire par pourquoi est ce que c'est
vrai c'est pas évident en fait il ya une
autre étape qui dit bombe en fait ça
soit pas très bien mais là j'ai mis un
peu un parti crise et la moitié d'un kit
du quart et la moitié du rectangle
orange
pourquoi ces deux là sont hugo parfaite
sait pas encore si facile en fait faux
faux ce qu'on remarque est que la partie
grise est ici en fait je change pas son
r si je déplace le sommet ici
parallèlement côté opposé ça se passe
que l'air d'un triangle c'est base pour
l'auteur est en fait la hauteur ce sera
toujours ça si je dépasse ce point ici
la hauteur sera toujours ça alors que la
base a pas changé du coup si je fais ce
triangle là il à la mer que celui là par
dépassement parallèle du point opposées
ensuite pour passer ne peut pas ce
triangle là à en faisant on le tourne de
90 degrés et ça nous donne ce triangle
là et ensuite on peut ramener ce point
là ici encore une fois parce que le côté
opposé du parallèle le côté opposé
et ça c'est la preuve originale du clip
de party crise et sont du coup de mer du
coup il est parti orange c'est le double
parties visées laissé amer et l'orangé
est égal aux oranje ont fait le même
raisonnement pour le verre on obtient
une joueuse du cloud à un argument
maintenant que je connais toutes les
étapes de calcul jusqu'à de vous
expliquer mais c'est quand même bizarre
je n'ai pas l'impression vraiment de
comprendre ça devient quelque chose
d'encore d'audace et magique et je
prétends pas contre vraiment s'être
preuve je la connais par intersection
assez alors la lauter les auteurs
dépasse donc voilà donc ça c'est la
preuve de clide et ça fait 20 ans que je
la connais en jeu la prise à l'époque
mais je suis pas sûr de pouvoir dire que
je la comprends pourquoi est ce que je
la comprends pas je pense que c'est
parce qu'en fait il ya beaucoup d'étapes
de raisonnement et l'accumulation des
étapes fait que d'un moment je suis un
peu perdue causé c'est pas un truc
instantanée dans la tête c'est une suite
de beaucoup d'étapes de calcul ça va
être un petit peu l'idée d importants de
qui se fout du moment a fait la
distinction entre apprendre et
comprendre en fait quand on sait qu'on
est capable de faire très peu d'étapes
de calcul pour arriver au résultat du
coup quasiment instantanée alors que
lorsqu'on apprend on est obligé de faire
enfin il ya plusieurs étapes de calcul
c'est laborieux on reviendra sur ses
idées plus tard en fait quand on parle
du terme de pythagore
moi j'ai une autre preuve en tête facile
la connaissez pour moi le théorème de
pythagore et pas trop compliqué je
comprends un peu près parce que j'essaie
de preuves en tête donc cette preuve là
c'est je prends un triangle rectangle je
fais copié collé quatre fois et je
dispose comme ça ça me fait
un carré avec un carnet à l'intérieur le
carré à l'intérieur c'est le carré de
l'hypothénuse et je peux bouger les
morceaux et j'obtiens ça et donc je peux
faire ça et là j'obtiens donc là
j'obtiens un carré de même taille et les
parties manquantes les partis qui sont
pas bleus basse etc les mêmes
c'est ce qui manque pour faire le quart
est totale et du coup la partie rouge
qui est la partie qui manque dans ce cas
va être égal à parti orange plus aux
verts qui l'écrit ce cas moi je pense
que je intuitivement je comprends que
cette preuve parce que elle est
quasiment instantanée dans ma tête je
vois le dessin prof
je sais que c'est vrai parce que ce
dessin mais alors je pense que je
comprend encore mieux terme de pythagore
que ce dessin mais c'est bizarre en fait
elle est là la vraie preuve que du
terrain de pythagore que je connais
c'est plus celle là en fait ça paraît
plus compliqué de prime abord mais bon
on a pas fait tout l'idée c'est de dire
bonjour en un espace vectoriel
mais je comprends bien les espaces
électeurs est bizarre et je prends une
forme binaire défini positive
ensuite il peut définir une norme à
partir de ça qui est la racine carrée du
produit scalaires entre x et x
et puis après j'ai ce calcul que je peux
développer ça me fait c'est juste un
calcul si les médias c'est l'identité
classique explique y au carré et puis je
vois que j'ai ça égale ça si et
seulement si ce terme est nulle et du
coup les termes de pythagore pour moi
avec ce que comprend le mieux depuis
lors un de pythagore c'est ça ce cas
c'est bizarre parce qu'apres il ya plus
à plein des tables de calcul vers tous
les français
a priori c'est beaucoup plus laborieux
que l'image de tout à l'heure mais ce
qui est assez bizarre c'est que pour moi
ça me paraît plus simple plus plus
instantané c'est plus ça c'est bizarre
quand il ya plein d'action me souviens
ce que je n'ai pas mais je ne suis pas
je les connais
cette année pour moi dans la tête du
coup j'ai l'impression de mieux les
comprendre que c'est assez bizarre c est
ce qui en fait la raison pour laquelle
j'aime vraiment bien cette preuve c'est
qu'en fait le terme de pythagore il faut
géométrie non euclidienne dire ouais
c'est géométrie euclidienne nono qui
viennent c'est parce qu'on apprend à
l'école mais c'est bizarre quand même
d'être vaincus de quelque chose de
savoir de d'affirmer qu'on a accompli
quelque chose qui ne sont même pas
compte que c'est un choix d'applications
limites et que j'aimerai dire que
quelque part comprendre c'est aussi
comprendre jusqu'où ça s'appliquer et il
sert vernières le fait que ça soit
fausse ça veut dire que les profs que
j'ai montré avant si on était convaincus
à 100% de ses preuves c'est qu'on n'a
pas fait quelque chose qu'on n'a pas
compris parce que yahiel et des trucs
dans l'épreuve que j'ai montré qu'ils
sont en fait faut qu'ils n'ont pas tout
le temps vraiment cassé c'est des
détails importants
j'espère vous avoir convaincus que le
turn de pythagore attentes om super
compliqué et que le comprendre c'est
très différent de l'avoir appris un
autre exemple de ça c'est un puissant
est égal à 2 je pense que vend ainsi on
pense à un truc le plus simple le truc
qu'on a compris
non lui dire que c'est un poussin est
égal à 2 et je pense avoir confié un
officiel à deux mais c'est pas si simple
et moi il m'a fallu du temps beaucoup de
temps et si on prend l'histoire des
mathématiques énormément de temps au
mathématicien pour comprendre un
puissant est égal à 2 bon on peut dire
que son quartier m comprenait un plus un
égale à 2 mai la première brave
rigoureuse de ça j'ai envie de dire
c'est un livre de
le prêtre de voir alfredo foued et
bertrand au sol weepu ça au bout de 3
170 pages
donc si des logiciens ont eu besoin de
370 pages pour ce combat encore de ça
parce que c'était un peu fort mais pour
vraiment saisir ça c'est que finalement
il est peut-être un truc plus subtile à
comprendre que ce qu'on croyait avoir
compris en particulier en fait dans un
[ __ ] est égal à 2 bon le 1 c'est pas
trop compliqué le deuxième 1 c'est même
que prenez ça ça va le 2 ça va a priori
mais l'addition déjà c'est pas simple
ayant fait la sinne égalité c'est une
atrocité
si vous creusez un petit peu le saint de
sens du cygne égalité soit vous concluez
que ça n'a pas de sens et que c'est
juste un symbole qui sert à lier des
trucs
soit vous êtes un peu plus constructif
c'est un peu ma prof de maths
constructive dont dubaï fait cette
construction ça me fait la même chose en
un certain sens que l'autre construction
même un plus un égale à 2 c'est pas il
ya beaucoup de choses à comprendre
derrière un puissant aygalades tout ça
pour dire ça en fait le l'un des
messages importants de cet exposé c'est
une citation de von neumann
alors je sais pas quel point ils
croyaient ça met donc à un moment il
aurait dit en tout cas que en
mathématiques on ne comprend pas les
choses on s'y habitue et alors pour le
contexte
a priori c'était à lorsqu'un étudiant
l'ua demande est la preuve de quelque
chose voix de manu on voit une preuve il
répond oui j'arrive à suivre la preuve
mais je comprends pas une bonne manne
ces dix jeunes hommes en mathématiques
on ne comprend pas les choses on s'y
habitue
alors pour ceux qui connaissent pas
avant demain ce mec est un monstre c'est
littéralement le dernier des abrutis
c'est le autrement dit c'est le promu
c'est sur le terrain des mecs les plus
intelligents dans l'histoire de
l'humanité élire sa page wikipédia
anglophone notamment ce mec c'est
vraiment une brute ainsi et il affirme
qu'en fait en maths on comprend pas les
choses on s'y habitue
alors je sais pas ouais je sais pas
comment interpréter ça exactement je
sais pas qu'est-ce qu'on veut nomade
vous voulez dire par sa part là mais je
veux affirmer que ça cette citation elle
est vachement vrai vachement en tout cas
basse et c'est vachement utile à pour
comprendre la différence entre apprendre
et comprendre
donc qu'est-ce que comprendre alors la
thèse que je vais défendre aujourd'hui
ma proposition c'est que en fait
comprendre c'est avant tout disposer de
beaucoup de bonnes choses ristic c'est
pas une approche algorithmique de ça
donc ça dit déjà qu'il faut beaucoup de
façons de faire lorsqu'on parle du
terrain de pythagore vous lorsqu'on part
de 26 ans est égale à 2 il ya beaucoup
de façons comprendre ça est une des
idées que je vais défendre c'est qu'en
fait chaque nouvelle façon de comprendre
ça est vraiment une avancée dans la
compréhension des choses que s'il suffit
pas d'avoir une façon d'apprendre les
liens que comme la preuve du terme de
pythagore
mais en fait c'est utile d'avoir toute
une armada de façon de penser le
problème est de prouver le théorème de
pythagore de penser en plus on est égal
à 2 et puis l'autre chose c'est la
notion de ristic qui est peut-être plus
importante encore une heuristique
donc c'est un c'est quelque chose un
calcul rapide on peut voir ça comme ça
toi c'est vraiment l'idée que le fonds d
ici c'est que comprendre c'est vraiment
disposé de plein de calculs rapides pour
penser les choses si l'on pense terme de
pythagore en fait j'étais lorsque vous
et montrez la preuve algébrique du
théorème de pythagore
en fait tout ça c'est s'est plaint de
quelques très rapide que je me suis
habitué et en fait ça habitués c'est se
construire tout plein de ristic
en son absence
donc là je pense comprendre un plus un
égale à 2 ou à l'internet enfin le temps
à des briques en tout cas de pythagore
parce que j'ai plein de seo ristic
quelques trains rapides qui permettent
de se sentir la chose et de l'avoir
plein d'angles différents donc petit
exercice 29 +46 est égal à combien alors
je pense avoir cette question vingt neuf
+46 quelqu'un a la réponse 7,25 à la
save et 75 premiers étaient là j'espère
que vous y est tous arrivé 9 + 46 cbl
combien 5
donc la réponse classique enfin la façon
classique de fer que nous apprend à
l'école notamment en primeur moi j'ai
appris ça c'est au gt gt gt doit donc
c'est c'est de faire neuf +6 les unités
ça fait quinze donc je pose de cinq je
retiens 1 puis je fais un + 2 + 4 plus
de ce fait 3 + 4 et 7
je pose de sept ça fait 7 75 75 pour les
français 75
est-ce que c'est comme ça que vous avez
fait quelqu'un peuvent décrire comment
il a fait oui ok donc ce que tu as fait
donc ce qu'il a fait d'abord de +4 ça
fait 6 2 7 6 et après tu as fait neuf
plus si ça fait 15 et a fait 60 plus 15
mois oui d'autres façons de faire quand
30 + 45 loi donc 29 c est 30 moins un an
et du coup moins ici qui très long mais
un autre côté ça fait 45 celui 30 + 45
et 75 d'autres façons de faire gagner
une autre façon quasiment identique oui
trois sur le premier chiffre est moins
sur le deuxième je suis pas sûr de
suivre ouais puisse 30 points à régler
ouais c'est une façon quasiment je pense
que c'est ma façon de faire ses jeux
fait 2-2 +4 pc enfin c'est quasiment la
même façon on sait depuis scott segal 6
puis je regarde si wayne fsi soit il y
aura une retenue
donc je fais cette et puis après je fais
le calcul des unités cesser ses mains on
a plein de façons en fait de résoudre ce
problème est en fait chacun un peu son
avantage notamment le moi j'aime bien le
29 en fait c'est 30 - 1 et paf ça fait
directement
ça fait très rapidement le calcul j'aime
j'aime bien ça à ce que s'est passé plus
rapide en fait je pense que ton termes
de temps de calcul c'est le plus rapide
après ça a le défaut de pas toujours
s'appliquer mais c'est intéressant aussi
parce que du coup bah si j'avais 27
c'est un petit peu plusieurs fois
obtenir 3 3 c'est trois fois plus qu un
du coup c'est un peu plus compliqué mais
c'est souvent ya ce genre de raccourcis
quoi et là on est vraiment dans une
situation on a une armée une armada de
deux domestiques
et puis enfin dans certains cas pas paf
on en a une qui marche quelle façon
quasiment instantané dans d'autres cas
ça pourrait être plus compliqué oui j'ai
supposé qu'on était en base 10 16 wipe
pascal bazin milliards c'est beaucoup
plus facile à faire comme quelques îlots
pas de retard ce qui est amusant c'est
que toutes les façons vous avais proposé
et je pense qu'en fait tu vois tous les
bons élèves ont des façons de résoudre
ce propos qui ne sont pas la façon
classique et je suis jeune je pense
qu'une norme corrélation entre ne pas
faire ce qu'on vous dit de faire et être
bon en mathématiques en tout cas sur ces
additions
sur les multiplications encore plus sur
les multiplications parce que là
l'addition encore on peut faire le
calcul
mais sur une multiplication bas c'était
29 x 47 x 46 bon premier réflexe de dire
ça à peu près 30 x 30 x 40 entre 40 ça
fait 2-0 trophée 4 ça fait douze mille
deux cents puis je pas affiné à peu près
ensuite mon calcul en disant qu'en fait
c'est assez de 46,15 moins de 40
donc bon c'est quasiment 45 c'est moitié
de 30 ans plus à 5 x 30 à l'inspection
50 ans + 1350
c'est ce genre de quelqu'un qui fait que
les élèves qui aiment faire ce genre de
raisonnement deviennent bons en maths
auprès fait en réfléchissant sur les
nombres s'entoure de tout tout tout une
armée de ristic pour résoudre ces
problèmes et le truc c'est que voilà on
s'y habitue
on est tellement habitué on les applique
tellement facilement que après on a
l'impression que ça des facultés que et
je pense qu'il ya un peu de ça parce que
les gens pensent que les les
ceux qui sont moins bons en maths pense
que ceux qui sont bons en maths ont des
facultés
alors qu'en fait c'est juste en
bidouillant les nombres d'un moment on
trouve ses origines peut ainsi habitués
viennent toutes seules et elles sont
quasiment instantanée comprend donc je
pense que valent à comprendre les
nombres c'est disposer de beaucoup de
ristic et qui permet de faire beaucoup
d'approximations autour des noms en
faites ce que je dis qu'il a aidé
beaucoup inspiré d'un livre de
psychologie de daniel kahneman donc
daniel kahneman c'est un prix nobel
d'économie il a écrit ce livre qui
s'appelait ticking fast and slow qui est
vraiment excellent je le conseille
vivement alors je conseille encore plus
de l'écouté que deux bières parce que il
un peu répétitif voyez j'ai des amis qui
ont essayé de lire qui n'ont pas fini
parce que
ça se répète un petit peu mais écoutez
c'est vraiment génial et l'idée
principale de ce livre c'est qu'il ya
deux modes de pensée il ya un mode de
pensée qui est lent qui est celui qu'on
utilise quand on attaque un prof de
maths on connaît pas du tout et faut
réfléchir
et puis l'autre mode de pensée qui est
instantanée très rapide très peu
épuisant on peut l'utiliser à longueur
de journée le procès qui les ai beaucoup
moins fiable a priori est une des idées
intéressantes de ce livre c'est que on
peut imaginer qu'en fait ce système ce
qu'il appelle le système rapide mais le
système est ainsi celui qui est
instantané c'est pas c'est pas un
système que l'on a acquis qui est pareil
advitam eternam
c'est quelque chose qui évolue et on
peut apprendre à ce système
un as à faire des heuristiques
typiquement sur les nombres sur les
petites additions certaines versions du
théorème de pythagore
je pense être capable de faire certaines
additions quasiment sans utiliser mon
système de vins parfois même sans le
système de la cim 10 1 + 1 c'est
instinctif cc2 quoi mais je sais par cas
mais je connais pas je sais vraiment pas
ce que j'essaie touristique qui calcule
très rapidement et en fait j'ai pas
besoin vraiment de réfléchir quand on
pose un puissant et riche en train de
faire le pt à savoir en question est
belle de mai je pense que ces essais
c'est le cas de pas mal de choses parce
qu'il est petit à petit il ya des
concepts de plus en plus compliqué que
j'arrive à gérer juste avec mon système
1 ça paraît stupéfiant aux autres
parfois on fait juste que ou d'un moment
le système a appris à faire ça et j'ai
plus besoin de réfléchir pour résoudre
certains problèmes et je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de ça chez vous pendre chez les
mathématiciens surtout est plus fort que
moi donc voilà donc un exemple à ce que
j'essaie cette robe skhira qui la voix
blanche les deux est ce que blanches et
dorées et quelques-uns est ce que vous
arrivez à l'avoir bleu et noir ceux qui
voient plancher de vrai nom et ceux qui
la voient bleu et noir ce que vous
arrivez à l'avoir blanches et dorées
ouais il va
il répond sa mauvaise foi
ouais bah moi je suis vraiment perturbé
parce que j'ai rarement j'arrive pas
l'avoir blancs et dorés et j'aimerais
vraiment un jeu j'ai fait tout ce que je
peux mais j'y arrive pas parce que
jamais avec cet exemple parce que je
trouve que cet exemple montre très bien
ses formes d'utilisation de notre
système insère la couleur de cette robe
on va dire n'a pas besoin de réfléchir
quoi est ce un truc instantanée est
convaincu de notre réseau et que les
autres ont tort donc là c'est vraiment
l'utilisation du système 1 et après doha
enfin parfois sur certains problèmes le
système de arrive à comprendre pourquoi
est ce qu'on peut penser l'autre mais
pas non à un changement de couleur et la
taille va l'avoir blanche et non c'est
vrai j'aime bien cet exemple et d'autres
actions alors que je passe à satie vent
bleu et doré y aller il ya des joueurs
visari si bleu et doré
ok je passe à la suivante qui est plus
ou jeu face à la turquie les plus
sérieuses dr on dit donne moi je pense
qu'il ya voyez des gens qui comprennent
le foot on va dire ça et donc donc ça
cette image si vous connaissez pas c'est
zidane finale de la ligue des champions
d'évidents signes ne trompent pas où est
donc il reste incroyable où il ya une
balle qui va très très haut dans le ciel
et puis une reprise de volée du gauche
en plus avaient passé en pleine lucarne
voilà pourquoi je raconte ça c'est parce
que mes mom et réunis à la place de mme
yade aujourd'hui place de zidane c'est
super dur en fait comme problème ce que
vous faites il ya la balle qui monte et
la balle comme elle est montée très très
haut dans ce cas elle redescend super
vite et on va en plus on est en plein
mouvement il ya plein de perception on
est on doit calculer le mouvement en
plus on doit la fouetter trappe non avec
le pied c'est qu'elles sont très grandes
du couffo c'est vraiment pas un truc
vraiment un truc pas facile que et plus
généralement en fait si vous regardez
les matchs de foot
les meilleurs joueurs du bouc et parfois
il ya des hauts des ballons qui vont
super roo et puis les gens savent pas où
est ce que la balle va tomber sans
vraiment aller parfois il ya des balles
comme ça j'en crois pas un peu dans tous
les sens comme si prédire où est ce que
la balle va tomber était un prêt et
ultra difficile et je pense que oui
c'est un prêt nul très difficile sur le
tapis les lois de newton et tout ça
médias le vent et tout ça et pas de
mouvement de la balle les effets magnus
et tout ça mais même si on était capable
de me disais tout cela en fait le temps
de calcul pourrait être assez long et
haut ce qui est assez incroyable avec
ses joueurs de foot où ces gens qui
s'entraîne beaucoup dans un domaine en
particulier c'est qu'en fait ils
arrivent à avoir une réaction quasiment
instantanée qui vont pas plus loin
d'être parfaite
même les meilleurs joueurs parfois ils
font des pas bizarre mais pas juste
prédire où est ce que la balle va tomber
c'est un problème de prédiction
extrêmement difficile et comprendre le
foot c'est aussi comprendre ça est
capable de prédire ou est-ce que la
balle va tomber quand on la voit sous un
certain angle et tout ça et c'est un peu
difficile et je pense que ses joueurs il
faut que l'on en fait ils sont vraiment
que tout un tas d'os ristic très
compliqué dans leur cerveau c'est dans
leur cerveau qui leur permettent de
sentir vraiment le quasiment
instantanément
instinctivement ou est-ce que la balle
va paraître dubaï donc ça c'est un autre
exemple de truc qui est l'opposé c'est
un problème de première année de prépa
c'est un des points qui m'a le plus
marqué comparez les partis de dakar et
avec les décroissent et avec bc des sous
ensembles da c'est que ce problème
beh les parricides est là et ensuite on
avait vu enfin le prof avait fait la
démo la démo fait cinq lignes
et c'est parce que j'ai une version un
peu longue mais la démo est pas longue 1
c'est plus court que la démonstration de
titres que vous montrez tout à l'heure
mais je comprenais je comprends à
chacune des étapes un jeu que je vois
l'argument qui a quitté tous à
comprendre cette démonstration mois mais
il m'a fallu un an pour y arriver
non je suis un peu long mais c'est
vraiment pas facile et en fait qu'est ce
que ça voulait dire comprendre dans ce
cas là c'est d'avoir une certaine
représentation beaucoup plus compliqué
finalement beaucoup plus visuel beaucoup
plus avec beaucoup beaucoup plus de
choses mais qui était beaucoup plus
instinctif beaucoup plus rapide à
calculer
gsk est un peu chiant aussi c'est que
cette façon plus visuel plus c'est plus
difficile à expliquer aussi ça vient du
fait que bon si on prend de bons il ya
une implication qui a sévi dans telle
autre implication enfin le fait que ben
et croissent et contient enfin que dans
paix doit à carrer il ya des ensembles
qui ne sont pas des bébés croise et ça
vient du fait que si vous prend deux
points qui sont pas sûres à diagonale
alors on obligeait de contenir tout le
carré au moins le quart est qui qui
contient ses points du coup ce qu'on ne
peut pas obtenir juste une diagonale
sans avoir tout le carré ça mais je suis
pas sûr que ça vous éclaire ce que vous
a dit et il m'a fallu beaucoup de temps
pour arriver à cette 7e ristic donc un
autre exemple que j'aime bien c'est le
jeu de la ville de conway
quelques règles très simples ils
essaient de prédire ce qui va se passer
vous posez quelle va être la couleur de
ce pixel là à l'infini est en fait une
question super difficile qu'ils sont
super difficile à laquelle il existe une
réponse très simple il suffit de faire
le calcul
si on fait le calcul bon mariage de six
mois oui ces extraits de sens étonnante
ça me permet de le citer et je sais même
plus où est le pixel que j'avais mis à
l'écran c'est il ya plein de trucs super
qui est compliqué c'est quasiment
impossible de prédire ça sans faire le
calcul
c'est super dur en tout cas de prédire
que mobutu 1382 l'itération ce pixel là
en fait et noir pourquoi et c'est parce
qu'en fait une longue étape de calcul et
que quand quelque chose prend beaucoup
de temps de quelques notre système n'est
pas capable de gérer et du coup vous
n'en a pas une compréhension instinctive
et du coup on ne le comprend pas c'est
un peu la thèse de 2,7 explosé alors
tout ça est lié pas mal à un article
arrivé de turing de 1950 il parle un peu
de tout ça en fait c'était pour rejeter
l'idée selon laquelle les machines sont
forcément mécanique est incapable de
créativité et ce que dit turing ses
suivants je lire l'idée que les machines
ne peuvent pas conduire à des surprises
est une conséquence je crois d'un
sophisme fallacieux auquel les
philosophe et mathématicien sont
particulièrement sujets il s'agit de
l'hypothèse selon laquelle dès qu'un
fait et présenter un esprit toutes les
conséquences de ce fait saute
immédiatement à l'esprit de celui ci
cette hypothèse est très utile dans
certains cas mais on oublie trop
facilement
elle peut être fausse autrement dit il
ya des systèmes mécaniques comme celui
qu'on vient de voir pouvoir purement
mécanique mécanique au sein se rendent
en calcul à la turing qui sont en fait
surprenant et qui en fait n'ont pas à
être de la créativité parce qu'on
n'était pas capable de les anticiper
en tout cas on en avait pas une une
vision immédiate
je pense que oui immédiatement et très
très important c'est vraiment la
différence entre je veux dire la
différence entre comprendre ne pas
comprendre c'est le fait que lorsqu'on
n'a pas compris c'est pas immédiat
quand on a compris c'est beaucoup plus
immédiat donc ce dans ce style on peut
poser la question voilà donc le nombre
2002 puissant smash 11,7 millions
quelque chose - en est aujourd'hui le
plus grand brun premier connu cette
phrase assez bizarre si vous y
réfléchissez
parce que c'est très facile de décrire
le nombre de points déjà nombreux ici
est ce qui est ce qu'il est vraiment
connu ce que vous connaissez toutes ces
décisions et ces chiffres ont pensé et
nombre a pas en principe on peut les
publier ça prend tout un livre de
beaucoup de pages
je crois que ça y est un mec fait ça sur
under faille il avait publié ça fait
trois volumes
trois gros volumes comme ça c'est un
gros chiffre au nombre donc bon connu
branquet on va dire qu'il est connu mais
pourquoi est ce qu'il est vraiment connu
donc donc dans un article scott aronson
qui parle pas mal de ces histoires de
complexité et qui prétend et je trouve
ça très convaincant que ces histoires de
complexité en fait sont fondamentales à
comprendre si on veut comprendre
l'épistémologie ou la philosophie toute
façon générale qui parle d'épistémologie
quantitative notamment saturé et ce
qu'il dit c'est que en fait ce nombre là
il est connu dans le sens qu un sens
assez précis qui est intéressant c'est
que il existe un algorithme très fin
rapide rapide qui calcule ce nombre
parce que les puissances en fait c'est
quelque chose de relativement facile à
calculer
il ya un algorithme entend logarithmique
en fait pour calculer ce nombre en fait
il a juste besoin de calculer les
chiffres quasiment instantanément en
temps quelques les proportionnelle on
temps qu'il faut pour écrire tous les
chiffres de ce nombre
et c'est en ça que en fait on connaît
parce qu'il est rapide à calculer mais
je peux très bien trouver un algorithme
qui sera très lent mais qui peut
calculer le nombre de nombreux premiers
suivant suffit de dire bon bah for rain
plus grand que ça et tester si les
premiers et si les premiers ont conclu
voilà j'ai un nouveau nombreux preneurs
j'appelle ma fonction
new prime et voilà j'ai une nouvelle
description hugo rythmique du nombres
premiers suivant est ce que dit anton
c'est que cet algorithme cela en fait il
n'est pas écrit pas vraiment un nombre
connu au sens où le temps de calcul de
cet algorithme est trop grand donc la
connaissance n'est pas limité par est-ce
qu'on peut le calculer
elle est limitée par est-ce qu'on peut
le calculer immédiatement je pense que
cette notion de hi media voir là c'est
pas tout à fait les médias c'est
proportionnel au nombre de chiffres mais
cette notion de temps de calcul rapide
en fait fondamental pour pour raisonner
quoi un autre exemple de tout ça c'est
le jeu de go nous avez sans doute
entendu parler de dalles tago qui a
battu ici dont l'un des meilleurs
joueurs de go puis maintenant ils les
ont battus le hac alpha 0 tous abattus
les tous les joueurs de gomme annoncé ça
c'est fou et peut être surpris que ça
ait pris autant de temps pour résoudre
le poème de go en fait résoudre le
prennent de gros c'est facile en fait
c'est assez facile de trouver un
algorithme qui résout le problème de go
qui trouve la stratégie optimale
le problème c'est le temps de calcul
parce que le ce taux ces algorithmes à
tester toutes les combinaisons il a
exploré tout l'arbre des possibilité
d'écrire une solution de ce problème
c'est très facile
ce qui nous intéresse c'est une solution
rapide à calculer de ce problème est là
tout de suite c'est un prix beaucoup
plus difficile c'est à peu près le même
gap conceptuel une certaine manière
qu'entre apprendre et comprendre on peut
savoir faire mais c'est pas dire qu'on
s'est fait rapidement très instinctive
de façon immédiate de façon sans
consommer beaucoup d'énergie de façon
instantanée
et ça on retrouve chez l'homme aussi
typiquement qu'on essaie d'apprendre le
cadeau il y en a qui m'ont dit ça
lorsqu'on essaie d'apprendre le piano en
fait il beaucoup une grande partie de
l'apprentissage qui est juste à prendre
au cdja apprendre en chine et le moment
sans y réfléchir
être capable de déléguer le fait
d'enchaîner différents mouvements sur le
piano au système de sorte qu'on ait le
plus besoin de réfléchir mais pour bien
jouer au piano
oui enfin c'est pas et qu'on apprend à
conduire au début impression qu il ya un
milliard de trucs à faire et à la fin on
est en train de texter ouais c'est pas
et qu'on apprend à marcher
vous faites tout ce qu on fait marcher
en fait marcher c'est assez difficile et
voyez désirent apprendre à marcher c'est
assez marrant elle n'y arrive pas mais
parce que c'est un peu difficile il faut
construire toute l'armada de récits
qu'autour de cerveau pour pouvoir faire
ça naturellement et sans y réfléchir un
peu pareil faire du vélo que tous ces
problèmes
en fait c'est vraiment avoir un système
entre performante nous paraissait de ça
c'est parce que vous savez ce que ça
c'est l'ombre premier c'est s'appelle je
suis pas conserver le truc du l'homme
c'est lui l'homme spirale de l'homme ou
pas vous écrivez 1 puis après deux trois
quatre cinq six en fait tu regardes vers
vous écrivez une ombre un spirale et
puis vous mettez un point bleu à chaque
fois que c'est un nombre premier et voir
pourquoi est-ce que vous montre ça c'est
parce que voilà comprendre les nombres
premiers
c'est capable de d'avoir plein de ristic
ils sont capables d'anticiper plein de
choses par rapport aux nombres premiers
et là on a un truc très simple et puis
on est surpris
moi je suis surpris par le fait qu'ils
ont fait les nombres premiers semblent
avoir des directions diagonale
privilégiées c'est assez surprenant et
en fait quand on dit comprendre et
nombreux premier qu'est ce qu'on veut
dire c'est vraiment avoir plein de
ristic en fait pour essayer d'anticiper
nombres premiers
je suis si la mini cela est sûr ça va
comme ça ça c'est le nom des nombres
premiers dont le terrain des nombres
premiers il nous dit que le nombre de
nombres premiers inférieur à nc à peu
près n / look de haine si je suis oublie
le blé prime de complexité c'est cette
formule a sert à rien parce que s'ils
ont envie de calculer le énième donc
premier juste à faire le calcul
mais le truc c'est que le calcul est
très très lent très difficile à faire et
le fait de se rendre compte que ses
équivalents à ça ça nous fournit une
heuristique pour anticiper les nombreux
premier par exemple pour pour être
capable de donner une probabilité sur
fait qu'un nombre très grand tirés au
hasard et premiers humains
c'est ça fait partie de l'apprentissage
le fait de la compréhension plutôt de
fait de s'entourer de ce genre
d'algorithmes qui est beaucoup plus
rapide et qui donne des résultats
beaucoup plus approximatif
donc tout ça c'est très bien résumé de
réinterpréter un peu ce que dit here and
now mais le tarn strauss et 1 médaille
fields 2010 6,6 me trompe pas c'est
aussi à une bille le number five où ils
le présentent comme le mathématicien le
plus intelligent en ce moment sur terre
c'est une énorme pour être très très
fort et il a écrit un billet de blog qui
s'appelle il ya plus en mathématiques
que de la rigueur et des preuves et donc
je vous lis la citation l'état idéal à
atteindre
et quand chaque argument heuristique
suggère naturellement un homologue
rigoureux et vice versa vous serez alors
capable d'attaquer l'épreuve de maths
avec les deux moitiés de votre cerveau à
la fois et il ya vraiment cette idée
dans ce billet de blog qu' il y aller
les intuitions où les arguments ristic
comme les appelle sont indispensables
pour bien faire des maths et qu'il faut
un communication entre des trucs bref on
est truc prouver et des trucs qui sont
pas forcément vrai qu son actif mais qui
permettent de vraiment guider le truc la
réflexion autour des trucs plus
rigoureux en fait dans cet article il
présente trois phases de l'apprentissage
mathématiques dit que dans un premier
temps quand on apprend les mathématiques
on est en phase très rigoureuse c'est à
dire qu'on fait vous jouissez même pas
c'est quoi la rigueur ça c'est à l'école
c'est souvent ça au début
après il ya la phase rigoureuse où là on
apprend la rigueur et on devient un
bourg baptiste prêt si c'est pas
justifié selon la théorie des ensembles
aux élèves sais c'est que c'est faux ça
rien d'en parler tout ça et d'après
terrain de ça il faudra pas dépasser ça
d'un moment il faut passer en phase qui
l'appelle post rigoureuse ou à ce moment
là on est ça remet de plein de ristic
alors ça ils ont ainsi qu'on les a
toujours eu mais je pense que en fait la
vraie différence entre la phase post
rigoureuse et à face rigoureuse
et que on va être capable de mesurer la
fiabilité que l'on peut avoir en aux
différents théorie stick est heureux on
est capable de voir dans quelle mesure
on peut faire confiance à un autre
système
c'est ce qu'on a compris ce qui est très
rapide et quand est ce que bon faut
prendre le temps de mieux réfléchir et
on n'est pas sûr de ce qu'on dit et je
pense pendant cette phase post
rigoureuse c'est vraiment la phase
barak est ce qu'on arrive à faire
vraiment en plus des liens entre
l'intuition et des trucs rigoureux c'est
vraiment la phase vraiment idéal où on a
vraiment saisir vraiment compris ce qui
se passait on est capable de savoir
quand est-ce qu'on peut vraiment faire
confiance à nos orestie que trop rapide
voilà donc pour finir après que sa femme
ait quelques s'appelle maintenant les
proverbes bayésiens je remette un peu
partout sur twitter donc quelques trucs
qui vont un peu dans ce sens donc ça
c'est une citation de georges box qui
disaient tous les modèles sont faux
certains sont utiles et je vais rajouter
y compris en mathématiques y compris
lorsqu on peut prouver rigoureusement
c'est qu' une très bonne façon de faire
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut utiliser cet
algorithme pas parfois trop lent pour
résoudre le problème il vaut peut-être
mieux de s'entourer de deux modèles qui
sont faux mais qui sont utiles et en
particulier dans ce sens utile signifie
notamment rapide en temps de calcul
alors une autre citation l'apprentissage
est une danse ça j'aime bien cet état si
basses et les citations de mon livre
du coup forcément je les admire donc
l'apprentissage est une danse l'idée
c'est que n'a jamais compris
on n'a jamais entièrement compris pitot
on peut toujours sans toit de plus de
ristic plus performantes plus rapides et
savoir jusqu alors leur dicte leur degré
de justesse et du coup voilà vous ai
parlé du théorème de pythagore au début
quand même de pythagore jeu j'apprends
petit à petit je n'aurais je continue à
danser sur cette expression et on n'a
jamais il n'y a pas y'a pas compris pas
compris il ya je pense que c'est un truc
quand on enseigne envie de dire à la il
a compris que non là il a un peu mieux
compris la gagner un peu en
trouver une nourrice tic pour comprendre
son truc mais il en faut plein d'autres
il n'y a pas encore assez bien mesurer
l'impact la validité de son os ristic
autre citation une forêt de modèles
prédictifs et plus sage que chacun de
ces arbres ça revient à dire qu'il faut
c'est très bien d'avoir plein de façons
différentes de penser le même problème
et c'est d'autant plus vrai quand on n'a
pas un degré de fiabilité très important
en au modèle vaut mieux avoir plein de
modèles qui si possible essayez de voir
le truc sur le plein d'angles différents
et puis si tous les modèles sont
concordants on peut avoir beaucoup plus
confiance on se comprend c'est et puis
elle se met la partie à ce moment-là
peut-être aller chercher une preuve plus
rigoureuse et finalement c'est quelque
chose que je pense qu'on fasse et
intuitivement on emprunte de matons
c'est de se dire bon bah je peux
attaquer de succès tant que sous cet
angle là ça suggère ça ça suggère ça a
c'est que ça doit être mon truc et pour
revenir à parler d oeil à ce qu'on peut
comprendre les ja qu'est ce que signifie
comprendre les ja bas et seulement ce
sens ça serait assez d'avoir des façons
assez midyat assez instinctive comment
lieu va va réagir va fonctionner
il ya un autre truc vous ai pas parlé
ici c'est la complexité de la
description des algorithmes qui est la
complexité de kolmogorov de solomonoff
sur une seule monofils comme moi c'est
un truc de détresse au beau fils tu es
tu
bref ça veut dire qu'il en fait il ya
des complexités qui sont pas
compressibles
il ya des trucs non et je pense que les
algorithmes
que l'on a qui font maintenant des
tailles de plusieurs méga octets si ce
n'est des gigaoctets
ces algorithmes sont très compliqués à
décrire du coup à lire c'est impossible
mais finalement c'est pas si différent
du cerveau humain est d'une certaine
manière je pense que il faut penser la
compréhension du cerveau des ziad de la
même manière que l'on pense la
compréhension du cerveau humain
allez avoir une théorique qui est plutôt
le fonctionnement du cerveau humain ça
sera pas possible
intuitivement on sent que c'est très
difficile
par contre avoir des théories qui
explique ce qui explique très bien
certains fonctionnements des eaux restic
sont capables de comprendre très
rapidement certains aspects du
fonctionnement du cerveau humain par
exemple typiquement system un système de
la théorie de canal
ce sont deux joueurs de risque qui
peuvent être extrêmement utile et
finalement cherché à comprendre aux
rumeurs chercher à comprendre les ja
c'est c'est sans doute chercher à nous
entourer de plein de doris tic pour
pouvoir anticiper plus rapidement le
fonctionnement du cerveau humain ou
désir voilà qu'est ce qu'on en a fini
avec cette présentation
l'occasion de vous rappeler que monsieur
fille thibault giraud qu'ikea philosophe
qui est une thèse de logique sur mind
games qui va venir ici à le pfl
pourparlers rien à voir avec cette aide
mais il va parler de deux super
intelligence donc notamment avec la
question comment intelligemment une
super intelligent ce qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire sur une super intelligent ce
nom qui sera là mercredi prochain donc
inscription obligatoire inscrivez vous
par contre c'est gratuit donc on skype
et inscrivez vous donc à 17h en co2
puisqu'on est en c1 promo ça mon livre
qui vient d'être finie il ya quelques
heures
oui version finale non en particulier le
ce dont je vous avais parlé ici pas mal
repris comme je la vitre 14 de ce livre
qui s'appelle vite et assez bien qu'ils
aient l'idée vraiment de s'extraire
important de s'entourer de trucs qui
sont peut-être très approximatif mais
dont le temps de calcul est quasiment
instantanée et je vais donc avec la
thèse que je veux vous rappeler que j'ai
défendue aujourd'hui c'est l'idée que
comprend c'est avant tout disposer d'une
forêt de bugs heuristique et j'ai
rajouté d'une excellente mais tao ristic
météoritique c'est une hostie qui est
capable de gérer les eaux ristic de se
dire bon bah là il faut que j'applique
ça c'est typiquement âgée à 29 c 30
moins utiles et 7 capable d'identifier
quels sont les héros stick à utiliser au
bon moment donc je prétends que c'est ça
quand on comprendre je vous remercie
pour votre attention et puis ici à des
questions question vous avez tout
compris
c'est entourée de plein d'algorithmes et
de ristic ouais quand tu parles d'une
excellente maîtrise tic
imaginons que quelqu'un se sont tour de
très bonnes critiques mais à une
médaille ristic qui du coup est
défaillante où ils vivent pas du coup à
faire le lien entre différents sujets ou
à différents touristique et son sujet de
d'appréhension par exemple dans un
exercice est ce que toi tu conseillerais
une certaine une autre proche que
utilisés mais m ristic défini ou est-ce
que c'est seulement là enfin est ce que
c'est la seule approche d'utiliser une
météorite est qui et puis après ouais
bah en fait
l'ornière faux faux faux quelque part
que l'autorité centrale dans le cerveau
qui est capable de te dire c'est un peu
comme si une autorité centrale avec
plein de ristic finances et autorité
centrale 7 mai cadre rustique comme je
l'appelle qui est vraiment le plus
important que c'est elle qui doit être
capable de dire ah ça c'est un problème
facile je peux l'envoyer le tél
ça c'est un problème difficile il faut
que je l'appelle le système de un truc
plus compliqué donc et je pense que
c'était dessus mais je pense que c'est
ce genre de raisonnement en fait c'est
pas spécifique à l'humain je pense que
je pense que les ja pour progresser
elles vont devoir absolument avoir cette
hiérarchie en gros entre cistes entre un
système rapide et plein de ristic rapide
et fait un truc plus lent quelqu'un de
raisonné de faire une chaire de
recherche dans un arbre a typiquement
qui sera plus lente
on cherchera ensuite à automatiser enfin
à prendre avec un algorithme plus rapide
pour revenir sur la définition d'une
ristic comme tu en parles et notamment
comme on les utilise nous pour penser
faire des calculs plus rapide etc
est-ce que c'est simplement un raccourci
éventuellement avec un résultat
approximatif
ou est-ce que
c'est plus large que ça ouais tels que
je vois c'est juste un raccourci calcul
très approximatif à passer ouais si son
pinceau maths il ya parfois il ya pas
typiquement algébrique de voir les
choses et façon géométrique de voir les
choses et là c'est difficile de parler
de ristic parce que c'est pas forcément
un truc très rapide mais ces cessions
vont très utile d'avoir ces deux ou
plusieurs angles de vue différents
est ce que tu penses enfin est ce que tu
vois une borne ce qu'on peut rendre
heuristique et du coup ce qui ne
pourrait pas être rendus à ristic c'est
par exemple en maths
toi tu pour toit dans un champ
vectorielle c'est presque ristic
mais ça l'est pas pour plein d'autres
personnes donc est ce que tu vois une
bord du coup ce que quelqu'un peut
acquérir comme heuristique ou pas alors
d'un point de vue ergonomique en fait il
existe une nourrice tic ultime qui
consiste à voir toutes les réponses
et si vous passer le test de turing par
exemple j'ai toutes les haies les
discussions imaginables et pour toute
discussion imaginable il ya la réponse
le crâne de ça c'est que c'est 20
vraiment très grands comme fichiers s'en
fiche et qui serait très largement
supérieur à tous des google l'univers
observable
du coup on est sûr que l'on peut pas le
faire dans notre ordinateur mais ça
montre qu'en principe du sahara n'y a
aucune limite à l'heuristique après
trouver des bonnes feuilles stx c'est un
peu difficile
mais en fait on peut toujours apprendre
un soap stade 2 du tableau ou de l'amap
quoi j'ai une autre question tout ça il
y avait des citations bayésienne à la
fin quel rapport avec avec le
parisianisme et puis les statistiques
viennent s'il y en a le baiia nisme je
n'ai pas prévu d'en parler c'est pas du
club à lysiane isme en fait c'est une
approche de philosophie du savoir tout
entier et notamment dans mon livre ce
que je prétends du chef du septième
chapitre donc au premier tiers c'est que
si on oublie est contrainte de puissance
de calcul la façon ultime de savoir
c'est d'appliquer la formule de baines
et du coup ça ça nous donne c'est
l'algorithme ultima à proximité d'une
certaine manière est du coup en
particulier cette météo ristic lac est
capable de dire toi tu sers à fort enfin
si l'on sait que la forme de baisses la
bonne façon de gérer toutes les ago et
où tous les auris tic on sent que cette
météoritique devra donc c'est pour ça
que la formule de base reste très
fondamentale est typiquement une des
façons de peu d'approximations mhz de
base c'est à dire au lieu de
m'intéresser à toutes les terreaux
imaginables je peux vouloir
m'intéressait uniquement aux théories
rapide à calculer au zoo ristic
donc c'est pour ça que je fais pas mal
de lien entre les deux
mais dans ce cas là est ce que dira
qu'un algorithme de machine learning ne
comprend pas ce qu'il fait est ce que ça
a du sens finalement ben si on prend sa
machine un accueil de machine learning
minimale son seul but c'est de résoudre
le problème
bailly les minima du coup il a même pas
de façon de penser à ce qui fait il ya
très peu de riz stic a priori donc d'une
certaine manière cette réflexion
suggèrent qu'en tout cas pour qu'un
algorithme comprennent ce qui fait faut
qu'ils soient pas minime à défaut faut
pas qu'ils se contentent de le problème
et petit à petit on se dirige vers ça
avant on avait des alcools de machines
on était très spécialisés pour un
problème donné et en fait on se rend
compte qu'il ya des arguments de leurs
balises et aussi pour parler ça qui en
fait si on fait un algorithme de machine
learning qui apprend plein de points
différents il ya transfert de
connaissances qui se passe et il est
déjà plus propice à avoir une météo
ristic avec plein de ristic et
comprendre un peu quels sont les auris
tic appliquées à quel moment parce
qu'elles sont plus rapides pas parce que
là est le problème de façon plus juste
et à ce moment là je pense qu'on pourra
dire que le lia comprend un peu mieux
les problèmes qu'elles traitent au sens
de ce que j'ai présenté aujourd'hui eon
ce qui concerne la météo ristic
est ce qu'elle est censée est-ce que
c'est censé être un espace de rack qui
sait exactement quel rustique utilisés
ou est-ce que ça peut être quelque chose
qui teste tout les yeux ristic qu'elle
en position et puis il récupère la
récupère la bonne par exemple si on a un
plein de talent grid machine learning
est ce qu'une bonne bataille ristic je
serais très inquiet kit esse chacune
et qui dit a su allier l'insula il ya
elle me donne une erreur plus faibles
officiers ou tournoi qui dit ah j'ai ce
problème
sergio utiliser celui-là puis c'est bon
et puis ça a marché et voilà comment on
doit se comporter cette médaille
heuristique
c'est un pas difficile pour moi de
prédire mais je pense que ce qui se
passera c'est que ça dépend des
problèmes quand il ya des problèmes ou
clairement ouais je n'ai pas besoin
impuissant et on donne la réponse je
sais une orestie que mon cerveau qui dit
eux tout court pas besoin d'aller
chercher midi à quatorze heures par
contre si c'est un peu un peu difficile
là ça peut être intéressant d'essayer
d'engager plusieurs éristique
différentes de prendre la moyenne comme
tu dis donc je pense que c'est vraiment
une météo ristic idéale elle est capable
de
de mesure la difficulté des problèmes
forcément il faut qu'elle fasse a très
rapidement que ce sera quelques
l'approximatif et de mieux dispatcher
peut-être une dernière question et après
je libéré du coup est ce que tu fais une
distinction entre les gens qui ont un
bon système en ont plein de ristic
mais pas de système 2 comme zidane enfin
j'imagine
et est ce qu'on les deux phares est ce
que ça serait pas mieux comprendre quand
même d'avoir les deux alors pour le foot
je sais pas mais je pense qu'en maths on
peut pas aller loin sans avoir un bon
système de coûts et un peu l'idée c'est
que faut avoir un système d'eau qui
entraîne le système ainsi comme le piano
je sais pas s'il ya besoin de tant de
systèmes de pour le piano mais en match
je pense vraiment faux et 7 capable
d'avoir un système plus long qui va
vraiment et chercher plus loin
et puis une fois qu'on a le chemin en
gros on peut on peut peut en fait on
peut générer des données que comme
machine comme pour pourra préfère de
machine learning dessus et c'est
exactement ce que fait alpha bon c'est
une réfléchit elle fagots un système
enfin potentiellement beaucoup plus lent
et puis après il va utiliser une
heuristique 11 il ya bon bah ouais cette
branche que de l'art des possibilités
c'est celle qu'il faut explorer donc je
pense que c'est je pense que pour
beaucoup de problèmes il faut un système
de 60 pour avoir un bon système en bas
je vous remercie de votre attention et
j'espère vous revoir dans deux semaines
avec la venue de monsieur prix
[Applaudissements]